it boiled down to a few main things to
me first of all
you have to be coachable any person
looking to be successful in this role
you have to be
willing to learn someone that's
solutions focused
and so i know there's a few people
recently have spoken a lot about people
who are
curious and inquisitive i think that's
really really important as well
and then these two kind of tie in
together but people are incredibly hard
working
of course is absolutely key to being
successful
but people that just know what they want
i think i've probably learned very early
on in
my career um you always have to know
what you're aiming for and what you're
striving for
i knew what i wanted to achieve what i
needed to achieve and that just kept
me motivated has it changed
yes is probably what i would say um now
do you have to have an element of money
motivation in recruitment i think you do
um the job is is too difficult
too much under pressure to do it if you
weren't motivated by money but i think
there are certain things that have maybe
overtaken money as a motivator or
certainly things that are important
particularly for graduates looking to
get into this role so
progression is key however they work
they want to have
a purpose they want to make sure
whatever they are doing they're getting
better and achieving every day
but the part is something that's having
a bigger and greater impact